la semaine à la jennifer lopez était
présente pour l'inauguration d'un centre
commercial au qatar une prestation de 20
minutes qui auraient été payées plus de
2 millions de dollars nets à laquelle
s'ajoutent les frais supplémentaires
hôtel tout ça et la chanteuse qui devait
même récidivé à los angeles la semaine
dernière la semaine prochaine pardon
avec un set de 20 minutes payer 2
millions de dollars aussi ou un ennemi
pour une compagnie aérienne
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
problème il n'y a pas que l ni à les
acteurs américains les célébrités
américaines et célébrités françaises
aussi à oui on va oser dénoncer
combien faut-il débourser pour se payer
20 minutes ou deux heures à maître gims
un ken jean jennifer lopez
tous les chiffres sont à regarder
c'était il ya tout juste un mois
kenji girac en concert mieux kenji girac
en concert très privé pour les salariés
d'une grande entreprise
on appelle ça aussi un showcase à 30000
euros les 20 minutes il a gagné sa
soirée lequel j
il n'est pas le seul à faire ce genre
d'extras offrir une star pour votre
mariage la bar mitsva de votre fils ou
pour la fête de fin d'année de votre cee
c'est désormais possible sur des sites
spécialisés de nombreux chanteurs sont
disponibles à la location
mika qui fait danser les employés d'une
marque de robot multifonction pour 40000
euros il est bien avec son costume
si vous avez plus de budget choisissez
david guetta cent mille euros pour
animer votre mariage et il sort sa plus
grosse bois ambiance festival assuré à
louer il y à aussi vite à parfaite pour
accompagner vos trajets sur de nouvelles
lignes de train
pas de passer de françois cavanna
hell avantage c'est qu'il y en a pour
tous les budgets de 860 euros pour
romane rausis candidat inconnu de la
nouvelle star
[Musique]
bon et ça va jusqu'à un million d'euros
pour que madonna chance à votre
anniversaire même tarif pour justin
timberlake ou beyoncé si vous n'avez pas
les moyens de vous payer ça il y à une
autre solution moyenne en 2006 en euros
vous pourrez papauté 30 minutes avec un
acteur du genre john travolta al pacino
ou sylvester stallone un juteux business
lancé par un homme d'affaires anglais et
qui permet aux stars de mettre du beurre
dans les épinards les pauvres on les
plaindrait presque dépensé plusieurs
milliers d'euros pour vous payer une
star ça vous choque
[Musique]
très beau sujet et puis en plus on va
dire la vérité on en revient lui sur les
français les américains voilà on parle
de tout le monde
donc y'a pas de soucis mais juste avant
deux pas de ce sujet une question de
téléspectateurs que je trouve très
touchante sur le hashtag tpm des beatles
est juste tout simplement loi note vous
heureuse
oui voilà à l'heure d'aujourd'hui je
peux dire je suis heureuse je vais
souvent dit mais je pense que je voulais
m'en convaincre mais maintenant je peux
le dire haut et fort oui je suis
heureuse et se recevoir de pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
l'utiliser combien coûte gagne star
privé est ce que vous êtes choqués ou
pas choquer on a vu des montants à
incroyable je crois que record c'est
l'anarchie dans les années 80 38 3
millions huit cent mille dollars pour
avoir deux heures de concert privé lors
de concerts 3 millions c'est vrai que
c'est des montants incroyable alors
choqué ou pas michael dorman et choquée
moi je suis très choqué mais je vous
dire pourquoi il ya un élément dont on
n'a pas parlé d'un reportage si vous
avez énormément de ses stars dont
beyoncé ou mariah carey qui ont chanté
pour les plus grands dictateurs du monde
absolu des concerts privés pour kadhafi
par des dictateurs africains d horreur
il quand on leur dit c'est pas bien il
répond pas parce qu'il revient à gbagbo
une question de salaire c'est bien de ça
l avait dit elle avait été chantée en
tunisie en libye pardon on lui avait dit
c'est pas bien j'avais gagné un million
de dollars elle avait rendu la somme
après à une association de gens voient
j'avoue j'ai presque tout cas isolé
palais moi j'ai une question très simple
vous poser parce que je juge personnes
pour 4 millions $ vous irez change vous
iriez passé une heure avec kadhafi il
est compliqué c'est un exemple vous en
sortez pas déjà très inquiète et qu'un
dictateur envie de payer pignon des rues
c'est pas la question estime jean guy
demers aimez vous le feriez ou pas a
bien sûr que non mais je vous dis je
auteur
merci les amis vous l'avait bien repéré
alors choqué donc un choc et choqué
encore catherine je suis complètement
d'accord avec mathieu pour 4 millions de
dollars quand on s'appelle beyoncé quand
on est riche et où on n'a pas à se
déplacer à se vendre un dictateur c'est
un tous les matches c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent ça un petit peu
choquant d'invités ou de payer si cher
des artistes bon je sais bien qu'à une
commune artistes magali la domestique et
ça c'est quand même beaucoup d'argent
c'est un peu indécent les donneurs par
la magie mais est ce que le plus
indécent c'est pas tant à la limite un
concert h pas un ou deux millions de
dollars sont des grands se sont non mais
ce sont des grand grand grand artiste se
payer ce pays voilà une star pour 2
milliards est ce que le plus choquant
c'est pas quand je lis par les 30
minutes avec sylvester stallone ou par
les 30 minutes avec un acteur c'est lui
par les 30 minutes 3000 $ c'est qu'elle
m'a dit sinon j'ai été contacté mois par
une boîte qui vous rendez vous qui
voulez me faire lancer une appli pour
pouvoir faire payer par son match et de
larmes aux pourparlers dix minutes avec
un fan ça fait c'est pas bête sur la
sadc mais moi j'ai accès physique à
refuser pour moi mais tu vas en avant
excusez mon agent on va mieux ça après
bébé on parle des autres d'abord il est
pas syrie n'a pas dit je n'ai pas de
santeuil une prestation dans une soirée
avec un concert c'est pas pareil juste
pour dire bonjour à tous et on paye pas
pour dire bonjour
alors est ce qu'on peut dire aussi là
j'ai lu par exemple j'ai vu dans le
sujet cent mille euros pour avoir kenji
girac dans un concert privé
c'est du one shot je pense que c'est ça
du père arrivé une fois prête cependant
qu'elle girac mois d'après mes
informations qui sont des informations
relativement sûrs qu'ils sont très
justes entre ea les vins etc attend et
40000 euros
une prestation des danseurs voilà mais
pas pareil pour les maître gims pour les
pour tous de matt pokora tout ce qu'on
entend de succès en ce moment on peut on
peut les avoir des odeurs dans un
concert prend 0,3 carburation c'est un
métier à temps je viens de changer mais
il ya une équipe jeune et belle et pas
choqué c'est pour voir les vrais
chiffres médium non moi moi je suis
choqué quand c'est des sommes qu'on vend
à descendre surtout que la moitié des
sommes
il ya la partie concert mais faut payer
en même temps le logement a bien
évidemment oui enfin c'est des sommes
hautement dingue moi ça me choque quand
sarah attend bien de serbie ont salvat
c'est quoi demandé l'iran en revanche
qui viennent faire un travail on
c'est des concerts privés en fait est
que y paient eux-mêmes leurs
collaborateurs leurs stylistes leur
coiffeur leur machin c'est assez normal
après on est dans des délires quand on
voit que mariah carey c'est un million
cinq elle vient 30 minutes et parfois
elle dit j'ai plus envie de le faire et
bien ça c'est autre chose mais j'ai pris
de la questionner leur enquête choc et
eden rouge produit la question à un
grand économiste un ancien président
enfin quelqu'un qui a du talent et qui
est brillant qui a fait des grandes
études qui va faire une conférence une
demi heure quelque part qui prend 100
mille dollars
pourquoi est ce que lui fait son métier
alors qu'une beyoncé qui va chanter de
pour une entreprise privée ne ferait pas
son métier parce que c'est des sommes
d'un mois mais ça ça ça se sentait pas
c'est plus importance des sommes mais
l'important c'est somme c'est pour plein
à plein d'autres choses de toute façon
un footballeur je trouve que c'est pas
mal à la côte et d'infirmières ça fait
très démago je sais ça tu es à wil hahn
de la démagogie
bah oui mais je ne peux pas dire c'est
vrai c'est pour ça que je dit choqué
c'est plus que j'explique ça lui arrive
quelque chose de nouveau c'est
l'importance des sommes et en même temps
j'étais en train de regarder j'étais un
peu l'esprit d'un blog ce joaillier
180000 euros pour patrick howell et je
me disais ce que j'ai la somme quoi
parce que l'euro c'est pas la nuit 1
c'est un dîner tous à cette institution
c'était parfois il ya quelques
particuliers il ya quelques partenaires
et de cailloux sur doctor de télévision
qui sont convoqués vous pouvez à
l'époque je donnais un vieux nombre
peut-être pas gens vous pouviez dîner
pour philippe bouvard pour 15000 euros
sert que vous vouliez dire vous ne
faisiez un dîner en disant j'ai envie de
montrer que j'ai des gens connus on y
avait des agences spécialisées et vous
faisiez venir avant qu'on appelle à
nîmes à moi je n'ai pas de tes pas de
jeu pas de problème moi juste une
commune de l'état quand il est invité
par exemple par un hôtel
haibi sa touche combien il touche ces
sommes là pourquoi il y aurait une
différence mais ton monsieur untel veut
la voir chez lui à ses cent mille
l'hôtel ushuaïa ibiza veut la voir ses
cent mille pour lui c'est pareil il fait
la même chose donc y a rien de choquant
j'entends en tout cas poursuivre idée là
dessus les prix qu'on a à peu près donc
à mears entre 30 et 40 mille euros kenji
on a dit aussi 30 millions à peu près
soprano pareil on a trente quarante
mille euros oscille entre 20 et 30 me
voilà patrick bruel on sera autour de
cent mille euros si vous la voir en
concert privé par l williams 450000
euros beyoncé un million et demi après
quand tu pars dans les américains ça
sans bobo
matthieu delormeau alors justement c'est
toi qui connais des tarifs comme il
voudrait de charme pour chanter ou si
c'est pourquoi juste être présent pour
changer de braquet santé c'est moi qui
paye dans les mines
[Rires]
dans la vidéo et oui c'est énorme mais
mariah carey prenions une miss 3000
c'est indécent parce que je veux c'est
en entendant ces mots qu anime c'est pas
vous